dea
今から日本語の講座を行います
日本語の失業と第4回開始
園3を勉強する気が湧いてこないどうしたらいいそうだねえん3の資格は食品取扱の
免許と同じようなものが取得するのに時間と努力が必要だが
取得したところで特にためにをならないもっともっと上を目指した方がいいと思う
例えばフグの調理師なんです文法がよくわからない
例えばいいですかといいんですか違いは何
よくある質問だこれは難しいようで実はとても簡単ですいいですか許可を求める文法で
いいんですかは radwimps 6
旭堂それはクマ a はたとえ話でありました勉強せずに尊前者の感情2週間で覚える
方法教えてください
なめてんのか勉強せずに n one 受けてその時中国人の解答用紙移すこと
日本語お上手ってよく言われるが本当に上手くなった時の証ってある
パイ決定的な瞬間があるそれは日本語お上手ではなく長いんですか日本はと聞かれた
とき
表現ですよろしくお願いします日本語お上手
う同源ですよろしくお願いしますだ
日本語お上手道元ですよろしくお願いします
仲いいんですか日本
[音楽]
日本語で皮肉を言う時のアクセントを教えてください
日本語には皮肉なんてない
私は日本で英語を教えたくていま alt に応募する準備をしている
何かためになる知識がある alt になれば英語を教えることができると思っている
ようだな
残念ながらこれは勘違いでや alt の仕事はキング牧師の私にを夢のある
を繰り返して再生するテープレコーダーになり時々
廊下の床の掃除をさ
いることだピザを注文する方法教えてください
去年日本にいた時この表現がわからなくてとても苦労した
ぴったりの表現が私の後についていってください
すみません私は来日してもファーストフードを食べる教養のないアメリカ人です助けて
くださいほんで日本語を勉強しようと思っている
各レベルで使えそうな
を教えてください初級者にもドラえもんの漫画中級者には金原ひとみのトリップ
トラップ
上級者には三島由紀夫の豊饒の海そして最終的には三島先生の美しい理念に染まり弦を
身を以て実行すること
[音楽]
nearest 4 a だ p 5 ios pei ling 菅井
オレンジ2
[音楽]
me
ni